what do you think is the most important
muscle for suggestions is it biceps no
uh I think a strong I think a strong
back I think back one core second
and then biceps okay biceps do you
legitimately think like weight lifting
helps Jujitsu it's kind of the
discussion on the steroids is like
the muscle mass and strength and power
and explosiveness all that I think
sometimes when we're at that upper
echelon of competition there's there's
only there's like little my new battles
that you have to win and if you're if
you're relatively close in technique
then a lot of times a stronger opponent
pulls it out
but it could be also just a limitation
right you hold position too long uh what
about for hobbyists do you recommend
weightlifting like when you see people
in the gym I always recommend
weightlifting I I almost see muscle as
the body's armor right the the more
armor you have the more damage you can
kind of take and you know maybe recovery
is a little bit better
um and I've always seen weightlifting as
a means to uh stick to my routine like
if there's no point in lifting if you're
not eating right and you're not sleeping
right so if you kind of put it all
together then it's it's beneficial
what about you guys you go do you go to
the gym I go to the gym yeah
leave it on the gym it's an elliptical
and that butt machine or uh yeah I focus
on the glutes heavily all right
uh what about like what about injury
prevention so on um how do you train to
uh minimize the risk of injury you guys
have all been pretty beat up you've
gotten a major injury with the ACL yeah
uh so how do you train to minimize
injury probably not the right guy to ask
yeah actually can you talk through your
injury like what happened yeah so uh
about one week prior to uh this last
80cc I was I was wrestling with um this
guy named Kenta who's also competing and
uh I went to go lift him from like a
rear body lock and he hooked the outside
of my leg and we just felt something pop
you know he felt a shift with his with
his leg and uh
when it first happened it hurt for like
the first 30 seconds and then I honestly
debated I was like maybe it was just you
know some freak thing I was like I've
literally thought about continuing the
session uh then the next day I woke up
and it was like super sore I was you
know limping around couldn't couldn't do
a full squat
um so it pretty much killed all of my
training for the entire week leading up
to the event so I couldn't train or
anything uh messed up the cut obviously
there's there's added nerves with that
too you know when you're not in the gym
every day leading up to the competition
uh I went out there I wasn't really able
to pull guard because I couldn't get you
know full heal the butt connection which
is inevitable with playing guard and I
was very uh hesitant to shoot as well so
I came out with the idea of just trying
to use hand fighting to to Tire uh my
first opponent out and then mainly look
to get to underhooks or over Hooks and
do mostly upper body wrestling in the
beginning of the match I you know
successfully got to an underhook I got
to your body lock he tried to roll and I
ended up in top position and side
control but it was during the no points
period and then as the match went on uh
I gassed out and eventually he ended up
taking me down and then scoring with uh
with two hooks on the back so what's the
injury yeah so I got an MRI actually
after the event I didn't if you waited
wait wait you waited until after the
event yeah I waited until after I was
like knowledge or ignorance is bliss
yeah exactly I was like I honestly I
don't even want to know what's wrong I
was like I just go out there compete um
you know I knew it was like the the
biggest event
um to date and uh I really wanted to do
it think about not doing it uh it
definitely was a thought in my head
especially that that uh the day after
you know it's always the worst day
whenever you have like a serious
injuries the day after uh and I was like
man I really can't do a full Squad I was
like I don't even know how I'm gonna be
able to do this uh it got a bit better
over as the uh the week went on
um but I was like man I I have to go out
there and compete I was like I'm it'll
always be in the back of my mind like
what if if I ended up pulling out what
did you think about this hole I thought
it was just being a [__] yeah
just slap him around just yell at him I
didn't think we pressured you we just
saw you make your own decision right
we're just like it's a tricky thing to
do like with a heavily like like a
serious injury like this we didn't know
that was the thing we didn't know
honestly initially I thought it was I
tore my lateral meniscus
um but that ended up not being the case
it ended up being a full ACL tear I was
actually super surprised when I got the
MRI results
um so yeah we didn't know how bad it
actually was what do you think about
that situation I think uh Nikki's a
tough kid and uh I mean when you're so
close to that competition you know
there's not many you don't get many
opportunities like that to compete in
front of you know 15 000 people it's
like you know props to you for pushing
through it and getting it and man he had
a close match for one of the best
Grapplers in his weight classes like you
know a few adjustments here and there
especially uh you know if he was able to
train previously leading up to that
match I think he pulls it up so some of
the things he mentioned is nerves so
there's extra nerves just because you're
underprepared yeah I mean you know
feeling underprepared you want to go
into a competition with you know the
confidence I did everything that I could
leading up to this event I trained as
much as I could and then when an injury
prevents that you start to doubt
yourself more how do you guys think
about injury how do you train you know
training with the best in the world
training to be the best in the world and
avoiding injury
as you've gotten you tore your bicep
yeah yeah I tore bicep yeah
dude honestly I I was I was a body I was
bodybuilding you know for like seven
years and no lie I did I trained biceps
like most days like almost that almost
every day in those seven years pretty
much I injured my I injured myself
that's so Jersey man anything else or
just the bosses just I mean no
yeah injured the bicep
um pretty much I the day before a
wrestling practice I had like a a killer
arm day and by arm day I just mean
training biceps
very rigorously getting a sick pump and
uh I go to wrestling practice the next
day you know pretty late I should have
been there I didn't get a proper warm-up
in and the first thing I do is I shake
hands and I go to shoot a single leg and
boom I just blew my arm out the the
first movement I did so just not being
warmed up properly in addition to you
know having a very vigorous arm day few
hours prior
you're the you hear that about warm up
so like what what are some lessons about
avoiding injury uh training I would say
number one is is warming up properly
make sure making sure your your body's
hot before you do hot stuff okay uh and
what does warm-up look like for you I
said Jiu Jitsu or non-juices stuff yeah
just for a warm-up in general I'll do
I'll do something like a uh if I'm
talking competition something like a uh
a jog walk back and forth a few times
than a Sprint jog a few times to get
that heart rate you know up and down
yeah and then uh I'll grab a partner I
actually just filmed a DVD uh or
instructional uh specifically on the
pre-match ritual
um in addition to that I'll I'll you
know grab a partner I'll drill so some
movements uh typically I'll drill some
bad things like I'll start from bottom
bottom mount bottom side control work
out from there and in pretty much like
20 minutes in I'm I'm hot and I'm ready
to go for you know rounds
well what about you Craig so what uh
what's what's the way to avoid injury
what's the worst injury you've had
what's the worst injury I don't even
know I'm pretty good pretty healthy yeah
whenever you whenever you quit in
practice I'm gonna have some mental way
has your heart ever been broken many
times many times but um there's a thing
I notice people to spend the most time
warming up
often the most injured
it's a strong correlation
I can't you can't argue with science I
remember you're right training with all
of a test Oliver ties would have a 60
Minute warm-up yeah surprise surprise
always injured yeah very common yeah I
find that very common the training room
now I think people it's how they train
like if you like me first sign of
discomfort oh back pedal you know push
through that stuff go too hard go when
you're too tired you know what I mean
get too emotional in the role I feel
like those are the times that I've been
hurt where I just like oh I can't let
this guy get me when I have that
attitude and try I believe it's how you
train and sort of obviously what does
this come from like uh positionally too
like because you're training against
some Killers I mean you're training
you're training you're training with him
and going probably pretty hard the prey
gets a little tired he's like yeah I'm
good for today once a month with Nikki
right that's it and then you quit like
30 seconds in just said yeah you know
you got to be safe you know
I like it what about you what have you
learned from the ACL
rehab yeah yeah
definitely would help uh
oh so you haven't been like I didn't get
surgery I didn't do essentially any
rehab I just have no ACL in my left leg
so what's it like having no energy guys
you've got two options surgery rehab
only Nikki goes I'll do nothing
definitely should pick up on the rehab
um what's what's rehab for that look
like like twice a day of doing some
weird
like bands or something it's good he's
laughing he's learned some valuable
lessons from about taking care of his
buddy yeah yeah what's it like just
training with no ACL uh so at the
beginning it was definitely a little
iffy you know I would have an occasional
Buckle like I'd just be wrestling with
somebody and go to step back and then it
buckled backwards a bit
um but honestly now like I haven't had a
single Buckle instance in a while uh it
feels a hundred percent normal when I
train uh it feels better than my other
knee to be honest like I've had I had my
Meniscus taken out in my right leg and
that one gets sore more often than the
the no ACL leg okay all right so putting
that aside Mr
is there wisdom you've learned from that
experience yeah uh or definitely you
should be doing rehab and and prehab you
know I think that you know especially if
you're a hobbyist or or a professional
uh athlete you should be lifting um you
know whether you're rehabbing an injury
or just for an injury prevention so I'm
actually closer to uh because I I've
trained my whole life like pretty hard
obviously just a hobbyist but like twice
a day did Judo wrestling all that never
broke anything never injured kind of
like similar philosophy except like last
year I guess a year and a half ago I got
a tiny like growing pool injury and it
still hasn't healed and I've been using
your approach of not giving a [__] yeah
and like all right surely this is gonna
heal it'll be fine but it hasn't but of
course if I was like an actual athlete I
would like probably still train through
it just [__] it figure it out but when
you have other stuff going on you just
kind of wait it out yeah but no I think
probably we have especially as you get
older you have to do that kind of stuff
I think it's important for people to you
know determine whether they're what
they're going through is an injury or
they're just hurt a little bit because
injury you know for sure take time
rehabit and get better but a lot of
people like they'll stubble toe or
something like oh you're out for a few
weeks you know so well that's that's the
problem with the injury I have it feels
like a stubbed toe so I was like all
right I'll just wait a couple days it'll
be fine and then a couple days later
it's not fine and you wait and then I
never got an MRI I never got any of that
it's like I'm sure I'll be fine yeah so
it's hard to know sometimes like
what is hard to know I feel like a lot
of people
will just not check it out be fine well
because there's several failure cases
there is a failure case of where
everything is a stub tote you're like
[__] it
like like you're bleeding everywhere
yeah that's fine whatever uh so you have
to be careful a lot a lot of a lot of
people can fall into that too I think
I'm in that category go to the doctor
why do you go to the doctor yeah
your best approach is typically wait
until something else gets hurt so that
you'll forget about the grain that's
yeah exactly that's I was hoping I was
hoping to get hurt so uh waiting for the
for the broken heart maybe okay